this is about ms-13 and we'll have
another announcement next week the
left-wing
group of people that are running our
cities are not doing the job that
they're supposed to be doing
we are going to seek the death penalty
against alexei
saiyans who is a leader
in in the eastern district of new york a
leader of ms-13
for decades the single biggest obstacle
to building a modern transportation
system
has been the mountains and mountains of
bureaucratic red tape in washington
dc we're cutting the federal permitting
timeline for a major
project from up to 20 years
or more hard to believe down to two
years or less
president trump and georgia talking
infrastructure and regulations and then
in the white house talking about going
after ms-13 that
horrible group that has done a lot of
damage and
murders across the the us going after
its leader
and the breaking news as we just
reported the national
organization association of police
organizations
endorsing president trump and just
moments ago
its president said they got a call from
from the president
thanking them uh for the endorsement
remember this organization endorsed
president obama vice president biden in
2008 2012 they didn't make an
endorsement in 2016
but the president mick mchale saying
that that the president said it was an
honor and wanted to let us all know how
important this endorsement was to him
personally and professionally
obviously it comes as efforts to defund
police departments
all over the country are springing up
let's bring in our panel susan page
washington bureau chief at usa today
washington post columnist mark thiessen
and kimberly strassel a member of the
editorial board at the wall street
journal
it seems kimberly that this is
significant for
the president at this moment when polls
showed show him trailing in key
battleground states
the organization of national police
organization
a significant organization
yeah so this is a function of what we're
now seeing as growing
unrest and violence it's one thing to
have protests and some civil unrest this
is now turning into a long hot summer of
violence and looting and it's putting a
new spotlight on this question
of law and order and rule and law of
cities and the president's embracing
that
one thing that i think is interesting
about that endorsement is it raises a
broader prospect of whether or not the
white house has some potential for
inroads with union votes
not just among police officers but
firefighters
uh people who work in infrastructure
and and fossil fuels because those are
going to be big points and flash points
of contention in this election
here's the governor of portland talking
about recent protests turned violent
there
the street violence in portland
absolutely needs to stop
trump troops in portland are definitely
not the answer
as we saw this only escalates the
tension
they're like war zones and if the city
isn't going to straighten it out of
local politicians or
in this case i don't say this for
political reasons they're all democrats
they're liberal
left-wing democrats and it's almost like
they think this is going to be this way
forever we're not going to put up with
that
the governor of oregon not the governor
of portland obviously but
the governor of oregon talking about
portland there susan page
we should point out that joe biden has
said publicly as recent as
recently as yesterday that he does not
support defunding police
but this is an issue in in different
cities especially where the violence is
continuing
well when we see this chaos in portland
and we see that
demonstration the violent demonstration
we saw in new york this
is the ideal backdrop for the campaign
theme that president
trump has been striking that it's a
dangerous world and you can't trust joe
biden
to protect your family and that we saw
that in a 30-second tv ad that the trump
campaign
put out today but i think the risk for
the president is he is
at odds in some way with the kind of the
mood of the country when it comes to
trying to think about
racial justice which was the spark for
these
protests uh it's not 1968 in a way it
feels a little like he's running
a 1968 campaign mark you know it was
overlooked by a lot of the press today
but that ms-13
announcement that the leader is has been
captured and they're going after the
death penalty
that's a big deal for some states that
have been dealing with that gang for a
while
it is and look the president is running
on law and order he's always been
campaigning talking about getting tough
with ms-13 and now
he's talking about getting tough with
looters and riders in these cities
uh and you know it's it's really it's it
and by the way in in portland
the federal the federal troops the trump
troops as the governor called it are
protecting federal buildings because the
portland police
aren't doing it uh there's there's been
23 million dollars in damage to
businesses in portland
uh from from these rises this is not
small stuff you know there's two ways of
looking at it and i'm kind of of two
minds on it on one hand
there's an argument to be saying let it
let the cities burn uh you know these
people elected feckless democratic
leaders
uh there they uh they wanted to they're
talking about defunding the police we'll
let them live with the consequences
of of those that leadership and if they
don't like it then they should do what
the people in new york did in the 1990s
and elected rudy giuliani
to clean things up but on the other hand
the argument is what about the minority
what about the business owners what
about the people there who ca you can't
just leave them
uh defenseless against mob violence and
the president has a responsibility
you know 500 million dollars of damage
in minneapolis because i said 23 million
in in
in portland the these people need to be
defended and if they're
if they're elected leaders won't do it
then it's up to the president to do it
meantime uh kimberly interesting back
and forth inside the white house
about dr anthony fauci peter navarro
advises the president in an usa today
op-ed dr
fauci has a good bedside manner with the
public but he's been wrong about
everything i have interacted
with him on so when you ask me whether i
listen to dr foundry's advice my answer
is
only with skepticism and caution here's
the president dr fauci and the vice
president today
he made a statement representing himself
he shouldn't be doing that no i i have a
very good relationship with anthony
it is a bit bizarre i don't really fully
understand it i think they realize now
that that was not a prudent thing to do
because it's only
reflecting negatively on them i can't
explain peter navarro he's in a world by
himself
tony fauci is a valued member of the
white house coronavirus task force we
just completed our latest meeting
today and uh we couldn't be more
grateful
for his steady council and the vice
president even putting out a picture of
that meeting uh kimberly your thoughts
yeah i mean the white house also said
that the nabarro piece had not been
vetted didn't go through the usual
process
and and that seems to have to be the
case because look in this case peter
navarro has not served the white house
well
um there the press and and critics have
been attempting to cause a rift in the
white house over its uh
pandemic response policy and and try to
suggest that there are issues between
fauci and the president for months now
and so why an advisor of his
would actually publish a piece that
further stokes that narrative and then
require the white house
to spend a good portion of the day
repairing that damage
it's just it's not serving the president
well uh susan last word i mean dan
scovino we mentioned last night had his
own twitter
post about uh dr fauci so it's not just
navarro
oh and i we think that peter norris is
reflecting an attitude that the
president has had
but not useful to have it at this moment
when his credibility on cobia 19 is low
and dr fauci's credibility on that front
is really high